[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis le seul candidat
habitant à trappistes et ma liste des
100 % entre à biste les 41 colistiers
sont tous des résidents des quartiers de
la ville de trappes
ils ont des engagements à trappes pour
les un président d'association douzaine
de présidents se sont engagés dans la
liste pour l'avenir de trappes et pour
les autres ils sont bénévoles dans les
associations qui font du soutien
scolaire les associations humanitaires
de la ville nous avons des délégués de
parents d'élèves des trappistes qui sont
ancrés dans le réel qui agissent déjà
depuis des années pour transformer leur
ville et au quotidien et qui l' ont pris
la responsabilité de s'engager
politiquement pour présenter un
programme dont considérons que la ville
de trappes a été bétonné ces dernières
années si la transformation urbaine
était nécessaire dans les années 2000
elle a été beaucoup trop loin notamment
dans les nouveaux quartiers et nous
constatons qu y compris dans les zones
pavillonnaires les quartiers sont
grignotées par le béton et des bâtiments
remplacent les petits pavillons il sera
temps de cesser la bétonisation c'est un
des engagements forts de m'attaquer et
au sein d'un programme nous avons mis
une priorité modernisme en hausse par la
création d'aires de jeux de proximité
pour que les familles puissent
s'épanouir dans un espace qui ne soit
pas encerclé par le bitume et le béton a
d'autre part
donc c'est une caractéristique de notre
équipe
[Applaudissements]
la première chose que je ferai c'est de
réunir les directeurs d'école de trappes
pour renouer une relation de confiance
avec ses directeurs et directrices la
relation entre la municipalité et
l'école s'est dégradée ces dernières
années par manque de confiance
par manque de travail en commun et donc
la première chose que je ferai c'est de
réunir ses directrices et directeurs
notamment pour organiser avec eux le
passage à la semaine de quatre jours dès
la prochaine rentrée scolaire
cela supposera évidemment que nous
travaillons main dans la main pour
assurer la continuité éducative que l'on
doit à nos enfants
faire en sorte que de le passage aux 4
jours soit accompagné d'un projet
périscolaire ambitieux notamment pour le
mercredi matin est également compulsion
mettre en oeuvre dès le mois de
septembre
lors d'études gratuites après l'école
qui permettra aux enfants rentrer à la
maison en ayant fait leurs devoirs
accompagnés par des enseignants
volontaires salariées par la ville sur
ce travail et par des animateurs
diplômés
sélectionné par la ligue 2
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]